how did martin luther king jr completely
change uhura's future on star trek keep
watching to find out
actor nichelle nichols did more than
perform the role of lieutenant uhura she
also played a substantial part in
shaping and inspiring the character to
begin with according to her memoir
beyond uhura star trek and other
memories nichols and future star trek
creator gene roddenberry first met in
1963 on the set of his previous
television series the lieutenant after
which they began a months-long romantic
relationship during their time together
roddenberry would make vague references
to a science fiction project he'd been
working on which he called wagon train
to the stars years later while nichols
was on tour as a singer in paris she
received a telegram from her agent
telling her that she had an important
audition for an upcoming show now very
famously known as star trek nichols was
invited to audition for star trek before
any specifics about her character had
been decided since her part had yet to
be written she auditioned by reading
scenes written for spock while waiting
for her meeting with roddenberry and his
production team nichols was immersed in
reading the novel uhuru by robert ruark
uhuru is swahili for freedom and
according to the documentary woman in
motion nichols suggested that this be
repurposed as her character's surname
accounts vary as to when the first name
of niota was decided upon but it first
appeared in the 1982 reference book star
trek 2 biographies and did not become
canonical until its use in the 2009 star
trek film
lieutenant uhura is unquestionably an
underserved character on star trek and
in the feature films that followed it
she never gets the same spotlight as
kirk spock mccoy or even scotty while
this is a completely fair criticism of
the show its producers and its writers
it has unfortunately led some fans and
critics to diminish the character of
uhura herself and her role in the
command staff of the uss enterprise
captain i have something to communicate
with you
she has nails that are way too long for
space at a glance it's easy to see uhura
as the woman reduced to placing captain
kirk's phone calls while the under use
of uhura is a glaring defect of the
series her contributions to the crew are
not unimportant merely underexposed as
chief communications officer uhura is
the nerve center of a crew of over 400
she's a department head managing the
rest of the communication staff meaning
anyone else you ever see at her post
plus other stations around the ship that
we never see she handles all inter and
intra-ship communications including
kirk's orders from starfleet and
imperatives issued to the rest of the
crew since the production of star trek
pre-dates our modern concept of
networked computers uhura essentially is
the network aboard the enterprise
manually routing information across its
hundreds of work consoles uhura being
away from her station would be the
equivalent of the internet going out on
the ship
by the end of the first season of star
trek in 1967 nichelle nichols was
frustrated with how little her character
got to do on the show according to
beyond uhura nichols suffered several
indignities during her time on star trek
her lines and subplots were frequently
cut from the script the studio secretly
ordered the mail room not to deliver her
fan letters and studio representatives
would make malicious racist comments
directly to her face having had enough
she told gene roddenberry that she would
be leaving the show to pursue a role on
broadway roddenberry asked her to take
the weekend to think about it as fate
would have it nichols was scheduled to
attend a fundraising event for the naacp
the very next day there nichols was
introduced to her greatest fan dr martin
luther king jr as recalled and beyond
uhura and in other interviews king told
her that uhura was an indispensable role
model for viewers particularly for black
children who he said needed to envision
themselves in a better future up to this
point she admitted in the documentary
woman in motion nichols had seen star
trek as just another acting job now
enlightened to the broader impact of her
presence on the show nichols retracted
her resignation the following monday and
would remain for the duration of the
series
in the star trek episode plato's
stepchildren lieutenant uhura and
captain kirk are telekinetically
compelled to kiss for the amusement of
bored aliens this caused quite a stir on
set episode director david alexander
insisted on capturing versions of the
scene both with and without the kiss in
case nbc affiliates refused to air the
interracial content michelle nichols and
william shatner performed the scene with
the kiss first insisting on dozens of
takes from different angles they left
time for only one take without the kiss
which shatner sabotaged by crossing his
eyes directly into the camera this
assured that the show's producers would
have no choice but to use one of the
takes where the pair kisses uhura and
kirk's kiss and plato's stepchildren is
sometimes cited as the first scripted
interracial kiss on television though
this is an exaggeration it's the
earliest known kiss between white and
black actors on american tv but actors
of other differing races had kissed on
tv previously and outside the united
states strictly speaking plato's
stepchildren wasn't even william
shatner's first interracial kiss on tv
as he and french vietnamese actress
franz nguyen kissed while performing a
scene from the play the world of susie
wong on the ed sullivan show in 1958. of
course these two events do carry
different cultural connotations the
actual earliest known kiss between black
and white actors on tv took place on
british television in 1962. nevertheless
uhura and kirk's kiss remains an
important moment in u.s television
history challenging cultural taboos
during one of the most tumultuous years
of the civil rights movement
though high in the command structure of
the uss enterprise uhura never gets the
chance to sit in the captain's chair
during the original series or any of her
appearances in feature films mr spock
sometimes i think if i hear that word
frequency once more i'll cry
she does however get to briefly take the
lead in star trek the animated series
the brief ink and paint revival of star
trek that aired between the cancellation
of the original series and the launch of
the film franchise in the 1973 episode
the lorelei signal siren-like aliens
from the taurean system transfix and
incapacitate the entire male population
of the enterprise leaving the ship's
remaining female officers to rescue them
uhura still voiced by nichelle nichols
takes command of the enterprise and
leads an away team comprised of herself
nurse chapel and several female security
officers due to chief engineering
officer scott's euphoric state of mind i
am assuming command of the enterprise
it's still a sad state of affairs that
the storytellers behind star trek the
animated series felt they needed to
arrange such a contrivance to get uhura
her moment in command as if it would
take every single man on the ship to be
out of commission for her to get her
turn
star trek made the leap to the big
screen in 1979 with star trek the motion
picture in which uhura still serves as
communications chief aboard the refitted
uss enterprise the classic crew mostly
sticks together throughout the six films
which see the gang receive a string of
promotions but remain in their familiar
posts with their found family uhura is
last seen in star trek vi the
undiscovered country at the rank of
commander thankfully uhura's journey
continues in print via the ongoing
series of star trek novels in vulcan's
forge uhura serves as spock's first
officer aboard the uss intrepid 2 where
she later succeeds him as captain the
short story the hero of my own life sees
her move on to a new command the uss
hermes where she serves as captain for
over a decade the novel catalyst of
sorrows reveals that at some time during
this command uhura is secretly recruited
into starfleet intelligence and served
concurrently at both posts for decades
as human lifespans are significantly
longer in the future of star trek
admiral uhura is revealed to be alive
and well and still working for
intelligence during the dominion war
which featured prominently in star trek
deep space nine at the age of 138.
a contradictory tale in the
autobiography of jean-luc picard
mentions that she is elected president
of the united federation of planets
while lieutenant uhura was television's
first black astronaut actress nichelle
nichols leveraged her character's
popularity to affect substantive change
in the real-life u.s space program her
involvement in real space activism began
in 1975 when a nasa presentation at a
star trek convention impressed upon her
the homogeneity of nasa's white male
astronaut pool nichols decided to take
it upon herself to create the change
that her tv character was supposed to
represent writing editorials for
newspapers and magazines questioning why
the pool of american astronauts was not
representative of the true demographics
of the united states these editorials
got the attention of nasa who invited
her to cooperate in revamping their
recruitment efforts for the upcoming
class of space shuttle astronauts oh i
said don't
not me they'll laugh at you
and they said not if they hear you speak
five minutes nichols agreed but wisely
did so as an independent contractor
rather than as some sort of mascot not
only did this preserve her credibility
but it also meant that she could hold
nasa accountable if they didn't hold up
their end if she lined up the qualified
candidates they asked for and nasa still
hired only white men she'd have the
leverage to sue nichols spent the latter
half of 1975 traveling the united states
spreading her vision of the space
program and personally recruiting much
of the nasa class of 1978 which would
include america's first six female
astronauts and first three
african-american astronauts
during the star trek renaissance of the
1980s and 90s nearly every core member
of the original series cast returned to
make appearances on star trek offshoots
except for nichelle nichols deforest
kelly leonard nimoy and james duhan each
returned as special guests on the next
generation duhan joined william shatner
and walter koenig in the crossover film
star trek generations george decay and
gracely whitney returned on an episode
of voyager but nichols never officially
reprised uhura after 1991's star trek vi
this isn't to say that nichols was never
invited to return to star trek but
perhaps that no invitation was
particularly enticing in 1996 nichols
was offered a cameo in the star trek
voyager episode flashback which had a
far more prominent role for her castmate
george takei as captain sulu nichols
declined feeling that her role was not
significant enough to warrant her
involvement
in 2009 star trek was rebooted as a big
budget blockbuster film series featuring
new versions of the original characters
with only leonard nimoy returning from
the original cast as a time-displaced
older spock uhura now portrayed by zoe
saldana had a much more prominent role
in the new film series than she had
previously in addition to being depicted
more explicitly as a genius polyglot
whose skill with languages saves the
crew on several occasions she and james
t kirk cross paths frequently at
starfleet academy as kirk is an infamous
nerdywell who also happens to be dating
her roommate the pair end up serving
aboard the uss enterprise together where
they eventually put aside their
differences uhura also gets to
participate more in the action adventure
side of trek than her television
counterpart and has a romantic subplot
with spock that runs across all three
films zoe saldana was offered the role
of uhura after already signing on to
play natiri and james cameron's sci-fi
behemoth avatar saldana was initially
hesitant to take on another demanding
role with an overlapping production
prompting a summit between cameron and
star trek director j.j abrams to ensure
that she wouldn't have to miss out on
either opportunity saldana joined star
trek with relatively little knowledge of
the franchise which is ironic zeldana
had previously portrayed a massive star
trek fan in steven spielberg's 2004 film
the terminal
uhura will forever be hailed as an icon
in the annals of science fiction history
and the character no matter who plays
her in the future will surely continue
to appear in future star trek reboots
and spin-offs for as long as the
franchise endures however as important
as uhura was to the television landscape
the woman who first brought her to life
the actors singer and activist nichelle
nichols was no less iconic sadly nichols
died on the night of july 30th 2022.
nichols had spent the last few years of
her life diagnosed with dementia she's
survived by her son kyle johnson who was
the one to reveal the news on her
official instagram account the morning
after her death there johnson wrote last
night my mother nichelle nichols
succumbed to natural causes and passed
away her light however like the ancient
galaxies now being seen for the first
time will remain for us and future
generations to enjoy learn from and draw
inspiration
[Music]